welcome back to new rock stars kids I'm
Sam Bosch and I hope you're having a
wonderful day previously on this channel
I did a breakdown of the very first Iron
Man film to go along with the MCU
rewatch you probably all doing leading
up to Avengers infinity war I'm a part
of it you should join me it's very fun
keep that train moving I'm here today to
talk about the second official film of
the MCU The Incredible Hulk starring
Edward Norton today I'm bringing you
every single Easter egg and hidden
reference I could possibly find in this
movie here's your spoiler warning for
this film the first Hulk film snow that
Angley made the TV show from the you
know 60s comics and all other MCU films
just cover our bases with everything
again here's a quick clip of me doing
some background dancing just a few
seconds that's all I could handle you're
very welcome let's kick this off let's
start with comic book references because
those are fun and because those are the
first ones I noticed first up the name
The Incredible Hulk the title of this
movie a throwback to both the comic and
the TV show of the same name I know most
of you know the origin of the Hulk
backwards and forwards but just to clear
things up since there have been a few
different iterations through the
different properties so let's discuss
the Incredible Hulk debuted in his very
own comic of the same name in May 1962
and was created by Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby the main man dr. Bruce Banner was
experimenting with a gamma ray bomb that
long story short detonated right in
front of him and doused him with some
gamma radiation granting him the ability
to transform into the Hulk now this
movie kind of seems to pull from a few
different adaptations of the whole the
opening scene of this film is a clear
recreation of the Incredible Hulk TV
show intro but also when we see Bruce
Banner hanging out in South America it
seems to also pick up where the angley
Hulk film left off in this film it also
adapts the Ultimate Universe origin of
the Hulk Banner is tasked with
recreating the Super Soldier Serum that
created Captain America but it goes
wrong and boom you get the Hulk that
also abomination but spoilers for later
on in this movie also fun fact director
Louis Leterrier originally wanted Mark
Ruffalo to play Bruce Banner in this
movie but Marvel and Universal push to
get Edward Norton a bigger star at the
time to play the Hulk because he's also
a very big fan of the character it just
made sense and also I didn't mind his
you know characterization but anyways
during the intro sequence were
introduced to a bunch of characters from
The Hulk comics let's run through them
quick first up Betty Ross one of the
most famous love interests of Bruce
Banner she debuted in the Incredible
Hulk number one in 1962 and has become a
Holker self at some times a Red Hulk to
be specific originally played by
Jennifer Connelly in the first hope film
she is replaced by Liv Tyler it's also
worth mentioning that Liv Tyler and
Jennifer Connelly have played similar
roles before specifically sisters in the
inventing the Abbott's film I haven't
seen that one but fun
we then see general Ross played by
William Hurt like Betty and Bruce
Thaddeus Thunderbolt Ross appeared in
The Incredible Hulk number 1 and spent
many decades hunting down Banner and
Hulk eventually he became Red Hulk and
even joined the Avengers I wouldn't mind
seeing the Red Hulk pop up in the MCU
but might be a little too crowded during
all these intros we start getting
flashes of top-secret files regarding
banner his project and his escape now
there are some awesome ties back to the
MCU here specifically Captain America
Civil War as for comic book references
though we do get some pretty awesome
hints to one of banner sidekicks but was
cut during the final draft of the script
check out that guy's name oh right ear
BAM that would be Rick Jones a very
popular b lister from the marvel comics
rick was accurately a sidekick to
Captain America Hulk Captain Marvel and
the Avengers he made his debut with the
rest of the whole gang in Hulk number 1
and has even become a hoax orts as well
crazy everybody's a-hole check out this
pic of him as a bomb pretty cool if you
ask me these files also highlight a
fairly popular Marvel character who is
played by Ty Burrell later in the film
not the man I would have thought to cast
in this part but is still well acted
check out the name right there that
would be dr. Samson aka doc Samson as it
were in the comics doc Samson is a
character who debuted in Incredible Hulk
number 141 in 71 he has super strength
nothing like banner of course but he got
his abilities when he siphoned them from
banners radiation know how that works
that's why he's coming for counterpart
has green hair Hulk's green green here
originally he was actually closer to the
biblical Samson where he got his
strength from his hair lengths but
eventually they kind of just dropped
that he got a haircut a little buzz cut
still green though that would be an
interesting character to pop up in
infinity war but that probably wouldn't
happen now let's scooch forward to Emil
Blonsky aka abomination who debuted in
the Incredible Hulk number 159 in 73
Emil was exposed to
similar game irradiation as Bruce
increasing his strengths aminah healing
abilities what-have-you his abilities
have changed a few times in the comics
but those are the basics that we see in
this movie
normally abomination has pointy ears
which we're going to be added to the
film version of a meal but the director
thought that in a fight Hulk would have
bitten them off
yikes so they cut him not they didn't
cut him they just didn't put him in the
movie
yikes again more fun facts Ray Stevenson
was in the right to play a meal but
eventually he went on to play Volstagg
in the Thor franchise r.i.p also though
did you know that race star Danny Marvel
movie way back when Ray was actually
Frank Castle at one point in the sequel
that most people didn't see Punisher war
zone oh boy that's a violent movie fun
facts moving forward in this film we get
references to the Super Soldier Serum by
General Ross referring to the serum that
turned Steve Rogers into Captain America
but more on that when we get to MCU
Easter eggs don't get eager scooching
forward to when Bruce has snuck into
Cova University check out who's eating
his pizza a young Martin Starr hey man
you look they're young and happy still
suckin valleys hurt you now guess who
he's playing Amadeus show that was a
name that you probably we're not gonna
guess because you probably went to IMDB
and saw that he was just credited as
computer nerd however in the
novelization of this movie I didn't know
people read those he is identified as
Amadeus Cho aka the totally awesome Hulk
this is both cool and not cool because
Amedeo is Korean and as far as I could
tell Martin Starr is not also he goes on
to play a teacher and spider-man
homecoming so does that mean that Alma
Diaz show is the t-shirt of Peter Parker
or is this character in the Hulk film
now mr. Harrington who knows probably
overthinking it as for who amedeo's show
is he's the eighth smartest person on
earth and is the current Hulk he got his
powers by removing them from Bruce to
save his life and now has a somewhat
better handle on them kind of spoilers
for the comic I highly recommend
checking out his series scooching
forward to the coal for Hulk
fight check out these two dumb kids
filming it I would have definitely run
away but obviously these kids are
important to hope lore because the
camera kind of stays on them for too
long so let's talk about them or at
least one of them since he's from the
comics I'll come back to that second one
in a little bit let's talk about Jim
Wilson who appeared in Incredible Hulk
issue number one three
in 1970 he was a sort of sidekick and
friend to Bruce Banner in Rick Jones
unfortunately he did die in the comics
pretty early on but thank you Marvel for
having him up here in a film scooching
for again we see the infamous purple
pants from every Hulk thing ever yay
then we meet dr. Samuel Sterns aka mr.
blue aka the leader oh look he's wearing
blue when they meet him that's lucky I
kind of wish this character would come
back to the MCU he'd be so cool to fight
the Avengers with the leader appeared in
tales to astonish number 62 in 1964 and
is known for his enormous noggin as well
as psionic abilities also he's super
smart that's what I want these movies a
mind-controlled Hulk which we kind of
got already in Avengers age of Ultron
but still it'd be fun moving forward to
the ultimate fight with abomination and
Hulk let's give a shout-out to Harlem
and how this fight always pops up in the
Netflix shows there it is but also we
got the famous hulk clap that
extinguishes the flames of the
helicopter right there and the hulk
smash that was just a pic was a little
silly of course but i actually really
enjoyed it but let's move on to MCU
references starting with the scene that
never made it into the film but was
brought up in another movie remember
when bruce mentions trying to kill
himself in the avengers but the hulk
stopped him well that scene was actually
supposed to be the opening of this film
where bruce goes to the arctic and tries
to blow his brains out only to be
stopped by the hulk and here we actually
see another avenger teased check out
this clip here
it's hard to tell but it was confirmed
that that right there that little circle
you see is supposed to be Captain
America frozen and ice being a human
popsicle it's basically been confirmed
but it does definitely make the First
Avenger film kind of confusing since
they find him in the ship still cool
though moving forward to the opening
montage again we see a ton of Easter
eggs like this reference to Nick Fury
which makes this movie the only phaser
on film not to have samuel l.jackson
appear in but this still counts to get
his name we also see Stark Industries
brought up a few times specifically with
the sonic cannons that were brought up
later in the film to fight the whole
these are actually really interesting
and they pop up later in another Marvel
movie fun fact but more on that soon
then we get a shot of the cryo super
soldiers serum with a bunch of
references to Captain America the First
Avenger first up dr. Reinstein aka dr.
Abraham Erskine the man who created the
Super Soldier Serum as well as the Vita
Rays the special rays that help bestow
individuals with these abilities which
you can see right there on the canister
also worth mentioning that the color of
the serum injected into Blonsky is
slightly off from the serum given to
Steve Rogers indicating that this might
not work so good it doesn't spoilers
moving forward again to the Hulk
freaking out in the rain we see him
throw a rock into the sky sure this is
probably gonna kill someone or something
way off in the distance but some fans on
the internet believe that there is
something hidden in the shot check out
this little speck way in the background
way out there do you see that a little
thing falling now a lot of people claim
that this was Thor's hammer falling cuz
there's lightning and it's an easter egg
but it idea was debunked it's not that
I'm pretty sure it's just the rock
falling again it's a big-ass rock that
definitely killed somebody later we see
the famous wh IH the fictitious news
network that we've seen in many MCU
properties here's a few clips several
witnesses are confirming that members of
the Avengers and unknown combatants were
here at the time I'm the only one that's
facing any consequences then we see the
famous shield logo when the army is
using the shield database to track
banner very cool then moving to the
campus fight for a second remember those
stark sonic weapons well take a look at
war machines weapon from Civil War oh
pretty fun throwback then back to the
Harlem fight remember when abomination
spits out a tooth after being hit in the
face
pretty scary er right pretty
intimidating well
this scene is replicated years later in
another film check out this clip new age
of Ultron very cool also worth
mentioning that this film does not have
a post credit scene huh I know it's sad
but because it's worth clarifying that
the final shot of this movie is of Tony
Stark meeting general Ross in that bar
and mentioning the Avengers yay finally
guys and girls let's talk about
pop-culture references like I said the
intro of this film is a recreation of
the whole TV series but there are even
more throwbacks to that series than you
might realize
sure we see Lou Ferrigno playing a
security guard yet again who if you
don't know played the Hulk in the TV
series but we also see courtship of
eddie's father playing on the TV right
here specifically when Bruce is flipping
through the channels t yeah right there
this is a nod to Bill Bixby who start in
that film as well as play David Banner
the star of the Hulk TV show David
Banner not Bruce more on that scene we
then meet Rickson Gracie who plays
Bruce's Aikido instructor Rickson Gracie
is an extremely popular jujitsu fighter
also I wanted to bring this up because
he does this weird breathing freaky
thing with his abdomen that I wanted to
show you on a loop here it goes moving
forward to a fund not to Stan Lee the
creator of The Hulk with Stan Lee's
pizza also Stan Lee the man running Stan
Lee's pizza is played by it Stan Lee now
paul shores that would've been fun I
wanted to say Stan Lee again he's played
by Paul shores who voiced many Marvel
characters in the past Bruce Banner
Rider Man happy Hogan Rick Jones the
list goes on and on also he looks like
Mario if he was aged up coming back to
the TV series for a second can you hear
that famous and theme that would play
when Bruce would move from town to town
that's right there also in this movie we
see general Ross on Fort Johnson which
is a nod to the Incredible Hulk show
creator Kenneth Johnson then back to the
campus fight for a second remember that
second kid that I brought up earlier
well is about to pay off because that
character's name is Jack McGee and this
is another throwback to the TV series ah
so many Jack McGee is a reporter who is
hunting down the Hulk in the TV show to
make him pay for his crimes next fans of
The Wire probably caught Michael Kenneth
Williams making a small appearance in
this very cool and finally the David
Banner reference I mentioned earlier in
the TV show Bruce went by David
banner so that at the end when he
receives the necklace under that fake
name David B seems like a final
throwback to the show we did it
Oh actually how could I forget our Stan
Lee cameo how could you miss this one
he's the man who died he's from drinking
banners blood yay now so final fun fact
Stan Lee and Lou Ferrigno are the only
two people to appear in both Hulk films
we did it guys we've made it hope you
guys enjoyed let me know if I missed
anything in which of these facts were
your favorite make sure you like this
video comment down below share and
subscribe the new rock stars make sure
you check out my other Ironman breakdown
I'm a big fan of that video hope you
guys are too tweet me your thoughts at
Sam bear on Twitter and I'll see you
guys next time